Selam Selam gençler kimyadası mısınız
kimyası ders kalın Hoş geldiniz Gençler
bu ders videomuzda metalik bağ üzerine
konuşacağız Daha önce İyonik bağ ve
kovalent bağ üzerine konuşmuştuk Umarım
güzel sağlıklı bir ders videosu olur
arkadaşlar Evet şimdi bakıyoruz
arkadaşlar ne görüyoruz Şimdi biz daha
önce metal ve ametal atomları nın
birleşerek ne oluşturur bu biliyoruz
arkadaşlar hatırlayalım İyonik bağ ı
oluşturduğu atılıyor değil mi Yok bağlı
bileşikler ne yapar arkadaşlar
metallerle ametaller arasında
gerçekleşir metal-ametal elektron midir
ametal öğretin analı şekilde düşünebilir
Ahmet Ali ve Ahmet arasında arkadaşlar
ne olur elektron ortaklaşması dayanan
kovalent bağlı bir yapı kovalent bağlı
bileşik oyuncaklara karşı Biz bunlara
molekül azında verdiğimiz daha önce
giderseniz anlatmıştık Peki metal ve
metal ne yapar Ardeşen metal metal bir
kere birleşik yapmaz o yüzden bu
en iyi kapatıyoruz burada biz bunu
yakalayalım Peki ne olursun Arkadaşlar
bunlar kendi aralarında alışım dediğimiz
bir homojen karışımlar vardır ve
çeliktir bronz dur bunları örnek olarak
verebiliriz Bunlar Arkadaşlar bir araya
gelerek metaller ki hangi bağlarla bir
araya gelen bilir misiniz ki metalik
Bağlar'da bir araya gelerek alaşımları
oluşturulan Peker o zaman mesaja
tonlarını kendi arasında veya başka bir
mesele tonuyla beraber bir arada tutan
kuvvetli etkileşim Bakın bu da bir
kuvvetle etmişimdir Biz Man ediyoruz
arkadaşlar burada metalik bağ alınır
arkadaş adında zaten metal var
görüyorsunuz ki mesela sonları
biliyorsun kuvvetimiz metalik bağ adını
verir şimdi Bakın arkadaşlar burada
örnekler vermiştim Sen magnezyum metali
atomları bir arada tutan veya kalsiyumu
örnek olarak verebiliriz sodyum örnek
verebiliriz çinko verebiliriz bakır
verebilir daha çok örneklerimiz
arkadaşlar kaldı verebiliriz kurşunu
verebilir Çünkü çok fazla metaller var
ama aynı zamanda bu metallerin
bir araya gelmesiyle oluşan çelik gibi
bronz gibi amalgam gibi bazı arkadaşlar
ne vardı burada alaşımlar vardı Bunlara
örnek olarak veririz şimdi metallerin
değerlik elektronları arkadaşlar atom
çekirdeği tarafından ne olur daha az
çekilir ve o yüzden bunlar ne yapacağız
serbest halde biraz daha özgür diyelim
arkadaş serbestliğinde biraz daha
özgürdür diyebiliyoruz Ayrıca arkadaşlar
metallerin ne vardı bir arkadaşlar boş
değerlik Orbital yeri vardır yani bu
orbitalleri boştur O yüzden bunlar bu
şekilde hareket edecekler şimdi bakalım
bakacağım bu bizim on mekanizmasına
geçelim isterseniz ben burada temsili
dört tane atom verdim arkadaşlar yani
baktığımız zaman protonlar çekirdekte
artı yüklü zat onu yazmadık görüntülerde
elektronlar varsa dört tane komşu atoll
bir araya gelmiş Şimdi arkadaşlar bu
metot ona ait bir atom olsun diyelim
işte 4 atom var Burada şimdi bu elektron
burada dönerken arkadaşlar serbest
olduğu için ya çok fazla çekilmediği
için bu ekran arkadaşlar gidiyor komşu
Evet Ee atom etrafında dönmeye başlıyor
aynı şekilde mesela bunun bu ekran USB
oto ait olan şöyle baktığımız zaman bu
burada dönerken arkadaşlar ay zaman ne
yapıyor burada dönüyor Hatta Arkadaşlar
ne yapıyor burada dönüyor Hatta
arkadaşlar burada dönüyor Evet tabii ki
diğer ekranlarda mesaj sürekli
baktığımızda ve bu da dönerken gelip
bunu dönebiliyor arkadaşlar Böyle git de
komşuya gidip burada dönebiliyor yani o
zaman Arkadaşlar bu da bir kargaşa söz
konusu oluyor Yani şöyle birşey oldu
aslına bakarsanız orada çekirdekler artı
ipi çekirdekler kalıyor arkadaşlar
etrafında ise pek çok elektron şu bu
elektronlar diğer işte komşu
elektronları bu şekilde Konuşan Tom
etrafında dönerek bunu bir elektron
yoğunluğu oluştuğunu arkadaşlar işte çok
sayıda bu elektron negatif yüklemek
sonra bir saniye burada baktığımda bir
elektron yoğunluğu var biliyorsunuz ki
biz bunu arkadaşlar elektron Denizi
adını veriyor Bakın bu metallerde olan
bir şeydir
Ben bunu arkadaş elektron bulutu diğer
kaynaklar da vardır O da tabii ki
bilelim arkadaşlar baktığımda buradaki
elektron yoğunluğu Biz elektron deniz
veya buz olarak düşünebiliriz işte
arkadaşlar buradaki elektron Denizi ile
yani baktığımız zaman bu da pek çok
elektron var diyorsunuz ki Tabii ki de
var pozitif çekirdekler var ve pozitif
metal kadrolarındaki oluşan Güçlü
etkileşim Arkadaşlar biz burada metalik
bağırıyor yani metalleri has bir
özellikle Arkadaşlar bu metallerin
elektron ları serbest olduğu için pek
çok elektron yoğunluğu biz böyle bu
şekilde görebiliyoruz meslek bağlı bu
şekilde oluyor peki şey bu elektron
Denizi sayesinde acaba bu metaller
arkadaşlar ne kazanıyorlar diye
baktığımız zaman baktığımız zaman kaç
ametallerin çok önemli özellikleri
vardır Ne gibi mesela metaliz ne
yapabiliriz tel ve levha haline
arkadaşlar getirebilir miyiz Evet
getirebiliriz işte Arkadaşlar bu özellik
sayesinde en önemlilerinden birisi bunu
belki de biz Meta
şu şekil verebiliyoruz ne Samet hala
kızgın olmuyor Arkadaşlar oradaki
tabakalarda lezyonlardan kayarak Biz ona
şekil verebiliriz aynı şekilde
arkadaşlar metaller biliyorsunuz kasa
Ali ne yapar arkadaşlar elektriği çok
güzel iletirler ve iyonik bağlı
bileşikler kasada elektrik akımı
iletemez ametaller elektriğine
yapabilirler iletebilir İşte bu neden o
kaynaklanıyor diye bakarsak elektronik
Çünkü orada serbest reklamlar var o
serbest elektronlar elektron Denizi
sayesinde ki hareketi sağlayarak
elektrik iletkenliği sağlayan bize
kazandı Peki başka yeni zaten metallerin
arkadaşlar parlaklığı vardı değil mi
parlaklık arkadaşlar o metalleri üstünü
gelir gider tekrardan geri gelir işte
enerji alır enerji verir o işte oradaki
arkadaşlar geri dönüşüm sayesinde
hatırladım o Bor modelini
hatırlıyorsunuz diye düşünüyorum ve
burada elektronlar elektron Denizi
sayesinde metale parlaklık kazandırır
aynı şekilde arkadaşlar metallerin
yapısında sert olması bu en son Denizi
sayesindedir diyebiliyoruz arkada bunu
bu çok önemli özelliklerdir metallerin
arkadaşlar Bunu da bunu söylemekte fayda
var Şimdi arkadaşlar gelelim ikinci
otumuz ametalik bunun sağlamış Yine çek
bunu sağlandığı Tabii ki metallerin
fiziksel özellikleri bilirler ne gibi
işlem noktası kaynama noktası gibi bakın
chimia sözel demiyoruz pis özellikler 4
kimyasal Uzaklar bir metalin bir
elementin tepkine girme isteği ile
alakalı bir durumdur Şimdi biz buna neye
bakacağız metalik bağın kuvvetler
arkadaşım arkadaşlar bilmeyecek bu ifade
ederken neden bahsetmiştik elektron
denizinden bahsetmiştik elektron
denizindeki elektron yoğunluğu ne kadar
fazlaysa Evet ne olur arkadaşlar bu
metalik bağ daha sağlam olmaz mı metalik
bayağı sağlam oldukça da arkadaşlar
sağlamlaşır diyelim ve bu şekilde olur E
daha fazla elime doktora kaynatıp o
Metin artacaktır şimdi o zaman
arkadaşlar düşünelim Şimdi biz
Arkadaşlar bir kere neden bahsetmiştik
bir çekirdek var diyelim şekilde
sağlıklı elektronlar var değil mi şimdi
elektron ne yapıyor çekirdekli etrafında
dönüyor şimdi bir tane
bu şeytan oldu döndü müşterim ya da
Arkadaşlar iki tane aikidonun döndüm
düşünelim iş elektron daha fazla olursa
buradaki elektron yoğunluğunun fazla
olduğunu söyleyebilir miyiz evet dedi
söyle biz o zaman demek ki Arkadaşlar
bir kere bu periyottaki elektron sayısı
yani değer beton seslinim arkadaşlar
aslında ama atom çapıyla olacak bile
şunu yanlış özlemişiz değerlik elektron
sayısı diyeceğiz de ereksiyon sayısıyla
Kaşar ne olacaktır doğru raf olacak
şimdi ne kadar çok elektron varsa atomun
etrafında dönen o kadar orada ne
yapacağız Bu da elektron denizi'ni yoğun
olarak bakacağız aynı zamanda arkadaşlar
çap var tabii ki bu ne yapıyor elektron
arkadaşlar baktığımız zaman birçok
etrafında dönüyor değil mi baktığımız
zaman E şimdi arkadaşlar şimdi küçük bir
çarp var bir de büyük bir çarpma
olduğunu seni şimdi bize burda hesap
şurada bir sürü atana kadar belki
arkadaşlar burada iki tur atacak
Dolayısıyla odan çatla ne olacak
Arkadaşlar bu da ters orantılıdır diye
ne demek ki atomun çapı ile ters
orantılıdır değerlik elektron sayısı da
doğru orantılıdır diye düşmesine alakalı
metalik bağın sağlamdır akıllıyız bunu
söyledi size arkadaşlar daha gidersiniz
hatırlayalım Şimdi biz sol tarafta
metalleri buluyorduk dedi aşağı doğru
gider çektikleri metal inaktiflik
olduğunu söyledi Çünkü daha kolay
elektronik o zaman bir ve iki yöne doğru
gidersek metre eni arkadaşlar aktifliği
atar yani daha kolay ne yapar elektron
verir aktifi artar değiliz ametalik
özellik artı halimiz ama biz burada
arkadaşlar ne istiyoruz değerlik
elektron sayısı artması için gerekli 18
nasıl artık bakın planın Bir de kağıdı
23 60 33 ve 34 1004 gibi Ozan sağa doğru
gidersek o metaline olarak aşağıda
erkeklerin sayısı artıyor yukarı doğru
gidersek ve çabuk küçülüyor o zaman
metalik aktiflik bir videomda artarsa
arkası 3 ve 4 günü doğru gidersek ne
olur metalin arkadaşlar metalik bağı
metalik bağın sağlamlığı arkadaşlar
mesajların sağlamlığı
de artar arkadaşlar bakın ametal üzere
düşünüyor Seni Ancak burada güle
gidersek Tabii ametaller vardı şefler
vardı Klor var onları görme Biz metal
arasında düşüneceğiz Tabii ki mesaneye
var burada baktınız var işte şurada
mesela alüminyum vardı ya burada vardı
şimdi baktım da sodyum vardır aşama
gözüm vardı burada baktığım zaman şimdi
magnezyum ve alüminyum düşünürsek
magnezyumun elektron verme kapısız daha
fazla yani aktifliği daha fazla drama
alüminyumun arkadaşlar metalik Burası
sağlandı daha fazla diye düşüne
biliyoruz Arkadaşlar şimdi biraz su
çözelim bakalım bunlarla ilgili anlamaya
çalışalım olayı Şimdi arkadaşlar sodyum
var magnezyum ve potasyum ama biz
bunların Öncelikle aşığın Amerika
kestiklerini kıyaslayınca sormuştunuz B
şıkkında eleman okulları kıyaslayınca
sonucun Nasıl yapacağız Arkadaşlar şöyle
bir şey çok basit aslında Ama tabi
dikkatli dikkatli olmakta fayda var
şimdi sodyum 11'i dağıttığımız önce
Arkadaşlar bu tarz onlarda ne yaparız
yer buluruz 2813 tane katman var ya
üçüncü periyot 1A grubu elementidir
magnezyumu dağıtır Sak ne olur İkisi
Yok ya ne oluyor üçüncü periyot iki
Avrupa oluyor potasyum bakarsak
arkadaşlar potasyumlu 19 biliyorsunuz ki
2881 bak Kaç katmamak döndü periyot ve
bira Hatta biz burada temsili bir peçete
çizersek Aslında şöyle bir şey
yapabiliriz değil mi Ee ne var elinde
bir ara IKEA grupları var Evet Ne var
arkadaşlar baktığımız zaman üçüncü pilot
var ve dördüncü pilot var Kim üçüncü
periyotta buna sodyum vardı burada
magnezyum vardı Bu da potasyum var biz
bu şöyle yerleştirdik Şimdi arkadaşlar
metalik aktiflik nasıl artardı sola ve
aşağı dolardan o zaman kim daha aktif
burada eve Yani şöyle elektronegatifliği
düşük olan şimdi rotasyonu o zaman Başka
baktığımız zaman edeceğiz potasyum
büyüktür Tabii ki sodyumdan sodyumda
büyüktür magnezyumdan değiliz Pekala
aşçı elma noktalarını kıyaslayın diye
sormuş B şıkkında Ayrıca bu şu demektir
metalik bağın sağlandığı bakın karakter
değil metalik bağın Sağlam
o kıyasa demektir Peki bu ne ya bağlı
arkadaşlar değerlik elektron sayısı
doğru çap ile arkadaşlar ters orantılı
şimdi bir kere arkadaşa baktığımız zaman
binanın elektron sayısı 12 12 o zaman
bir kere magnezyumun arkadaşlar hem de
erkek thrown sayısı iki fazla yani
sodyum ve potasyum ona hem de zaten
çatıda küçük çap sağa doğru düşen bir
şeydi azalan bir şey yukarı doğru düşen
bir şeydi yani işimize gelen bir şey
olası Arkadaşlar biz burada el noktanın
kıyaslarsak magnezyum ev noktası en
fazla olacaktır Pekala sodyum ve
potasyum bakalım şimdi sodyumu çapı bu
kadar Ken potasyumun çapı ise bu kadar
değil mi şimdi araca sodyum etrafında
mesela baktığım zaman ve potasyum
etrafına baktı ek olarak dönüyor Tabii
ki baktığımız zaman Ee küçük bir daire
mi daha fazla tutarsınız büyüklüğü
dağılımı daha fazla tarz tabi küçük tane
daha fazla satabilirsiniz o zaman oldu
arkadaşlar sodyumun çapını küçük olması
bu da dezavantajdır o zaman arkadaşlar
ne olur sodyum büyüktür fotoğrafı bak ne
oldu ara
bu aşkı potasyum sodyum magnezyum oldu b
şıkkı damar magnezyum sodyum potasyum
oldu yani Zaten aslında birbirine tam
tersi de olmuş olur Ne alakalı metalik
aktiflik mi bu bağın sağlamlığı bir
şekilde düşünebilir Evet şimdi
Arkadaşlar biz konuyu anlattık şimdi bu
konularla alakalı Bizim kitaplarımız
vardı hatırlıyorsunuz buradan ben bazı
sorular seçtim sizler için tavuk tatlı
ben size ölürüm arkadaşlar Çünkü çok
fazla soru var zaten kitaplarımıza Evet
şimdi burada bazı ifadeler var bu
ifadelerle baktığım zaman ne Orada
yanlış olarak biz bunu değerlendireceğiz
bakalım metallerde elektronları atom
çekirdekleri tarafından tabi ne olur
zayıf tutun Evet bunu daha önce
bahsetmiştim metallerin daha zayıf
çektiğini söylemiştim Pekala arkadaşlar
metallerinde erkek elektronları başka
atomların boş bulunan katmanlarına
yapabilirdi geçebilir değil mi Çünkü
metaller böyle bir özelliği var ay zayıf
çekildiği için rahat olur vermek istiyor
arkadaşlar Hem o şekilde konuları
çektiği için ne yapıyor o da arkadaşlar
da başka
de bir tane boş katmanlara gidebilir
Peki arayacağım metallerin değerlik
elektronlarını hareketli olması metalik
kristalin kırılganlığı ayı kırgın
olsaydın da şekil veremez dik arkadaşlar
kırmızı olmasına sebep olur demiş
Haydarpaşa Burada yanlış bir ifade
vardır Doğru doğru yanlış cevap bu da
Denizli olacaktır devam edelim
arkadaşlar Bakın ben bunu Biz temsili
Paris cetvel vermişim x y z t ve K
elementleri var bunlarla ilgili olarak
hangisinin doğru olduğunuz ise sormuştu
Şimdi bakalım arkadaşlar ne yapacağız
şimdi xy&z için ağabey şıklık diğer de
beraber değerlendiririz isterseniz
arkadaşlar burada üçünden meslek bal
kuvvetini sormuşum Şimdi hatırladım
metalik bağ kuvveti deyince sağa doğru
yukarı doğru artar O zaman ben buna
metalik bağın kuvvetin diye bakarsak
metalik bağın sağlamlığı ya da kuvveti
arkadaşlar bakın karakterli kuvveti
olarak baktığımız var Çin büyük
olacaktır ye büyüktür x büyüktür ne
olacak o zaman bakın ilk kat olarak
metalik
bu sie den büyüktür ifadesi yanlış
oluyor Ziraat olması metalik bağ kuvveti
de ilk sen büyük ifadesi yanlış olmuş
oluyor şimdi bakalım bakacak chavez'e
bakalım şimdi ç d burada metal demedin
arkadaşlar ikisi aynı periyotta göğüsün
Şimdi arkadaşlar metalik bağ ben bu da
elime noktası dersek gelecek bu
kuvvetine göre bakmamız lazım yani
karaktere göre yemek bu kuvveti verememe
kaynaklarına bakacağız efsane olmak daha
avantajlı olma göre Ozan sevme Selin
buradaki eze göre daha büyük bir kuvveti
olduğunu söyleyebiliriz o zaman
Arkadaşlar bu da peynirimizi neden büyük
ifadesi doğru olmuş olacaklar diğer
sonra da bakalım İlk 2K bileşiği su
çözülmez arkadaşlar ilk bileşiği bir
arada yükü artı bir zekaya bakalım kavga
6.ana 6 Ada metal acaba yapınca kanun
yükü eksik olur çaprazlama kuralından
biliyorsunuz ki ilk iki kabile schibu
bileşik iyonik bağlı bileşik Çünkü metal
ve ametal olan oluşan bileşik iyonik
bağlı değil mi arkadaş
bu metal ve ametal oluşturabilirsiniz ki
o zaman Bunlar Tabii ki suda çözünürler
de çoğunlukla arkadaşlar o yüzden bu
doğru olur ve yeka-1 İçine bakalım YK
bakın diye IKEA'da yüküne artı 2K zaten
6.ada yük -2 mesela metal YK bileşiklere
iyonik bağlı bileşik bir ama sıvı hale
yemek bağlı Elektrik akımını iletirler
bu iletmezler demiş o yüzden Arkadaşlar
bu da olmaz şimdi bunu Biz arkadaşlar
yanlışı soruyorduk doğru olan çocuk
bunda yanlışlık Bu da yanlıştı O zaman
burada gençler cevabınız c şıkkı
olacaktır yani değinelim noktası zeyden
daha büyük olduğunu bir söyleyeceğiz
Arkadaşlar bu da evet diğer suyumuza
bakalım şimdi burada bir size üç tane
örnek vermiş İşte ne var burada taşa
baktığım zaman çiftler var x-y-z TR
Coupe çiftliği var Bunlar alakalı
aradaki bağı kuvvetini Daha doğrusu
balın tüylü sormuş uzayacak bu denen yer
bulacaksınız x11 yan hemen ne yapıyor
281 yani üçüncü kilo
o olan X'in burada biz mesela olduğunu
söyleyebiliriz ye bakalım 283 O da
üçüncü periyot 3A o zaman buradan oldu
bu da metaldir hem ethernet arasındaki
kuvvetimiz ne olarak kaça Tabii ki
metalik bayağı mı demektir alaşım
yapmışlar şimdi Z'ye bakalım Z1 Evet Z1
deyince Arkadaşlar ben de olur bir
olunca bir pilot bira Şimdi hemen bir
ağlıyor metal gibi düşünebilirsiniz ama
Arkadaşlar bu hidrojendir istisnai bir
durumdur Bu Ahmet abi arkadaşlara metal
olduğunu Z'nin söyleyelim peçeteye
bakalım seni nasıl dağıtırız teyze
arkadaşlar şuraya yazalım hemen neymiş
dokunmuş ikiye dağıtırsa ki ki periyot
ve 7A grubu da ve tahliye davaları
vermez o zaman Ahmet arasında hangi bağ
vardı tabii ki kovalent bağ vardır diye
söyleyeceğiz Aleyna kuyu dağıtırız qy19
2881 bakın olup doğru Ferit bira yani
kuyumuz metal olmuş oluyor p bakalım P7
dağıtır saat içi 5 de dağıtırsa ikinci
15 A grubu yani ametallere metal
haritalarındaki bir işinize iyonik bağlı
bileşik bir hepsini sağlayan
çıktığımızda Bursa olmuş olur arkadaşlar
Evet bir tane pirinç cetvelle gibi
sorumuz var ona bakalım isterseniz x-y-z
kahveli elementlerin Biz burada
görüyoruz şimdi bakalım ilk s bir
elektron verirse ne yaptınız elektron
sayısı olacak şimdi arkadaş ise bakalım
ilk s 12344 Ferit bira Grup elementi
diyerekten versene yapar otomatikman
üçüncü periyot 8 aldık ile elementine
benzer zaten kararlı olmak için reklam
vereni buna benzer ya bu hafta
potasyumlu bu argoncu görüyorsunuz ki
temsil bunu ismini elementini büyük bir
zaman Evet Oysa bu doğru olarak aşağı
biz yanlış oldu bulmak istiyoruz yer
Evet Z den oluşan homojen karışım Etlik
Bağcı arkadaşlar Ye bakalım ye Zaten
burada 2A grubu elementleri metaldir
Peki Z'ye bakalım bakın Burası 2 A
Burası 3B Bu dört ve arkadaşlar size de
burada metal Çünkü B grubu ne demektir
bu nelerdir metal metal arkadaşlar ne
yapar alaşımları yani homojen karışım
oluşturma ve bunlarda metalik bağ için
ifadesi doğru olmuş olur Şimdi
arkadaşlar ye Toprak alkali metal mi Eye
iki temel elementi ve €2 bilenleriniz
Toprak alkali metal diyoruz o yüzden
bunu doğruluyor ilk saatini veya artık
arkadaşın ilk bir tane verirse Bakın iki
foto ss19 oluyor bir tane verince 18
olur değil mi diye bakın yeni Proton
Sinan yanında 20 olur Çünkü doğru uçağa
iki tane ol verince O da 18 akşam bakın
kimyasal özellikleri tabii ki farklı
kimyasal özellikle Bak şöyle birşey
simyasız ile benzer de doğruydu ama aynı
mıdır farklı mı Evet farklıdır benzer
ama farklı neden farklı çünkü Proton
sayılarının farklı olmasından kaynaklı
yalnız kimya sözel aynı olabilmesi için
Proton sayısıyla elektron sayısı aynı
masala tam ekran sade aynı gelmiş Evet
ama fotosenteze aynı gelmediği için evet
kimya sıcakları farklıdır Doğru ifadesi
kadar
bu eklenti midir arkadaşlar Şimdi yukarı
sistemine göre biz ne yapabiliriz
grupları sallandırdı girdik bakın Burası
bir grup 2 grup Ayrıca Burası şurada 3B
4B 5B 10 tane grup var biliyorsunuz ki
burası üçüncü grup 4 Grup 5 grup 6 grup
yeni grup 8 grup 9 Groupon Groupon bir
grup 12 grup aşaması 13 Grup nasıl 19
Gen4 atamız 14 grupta dörtlü Grup 4B
grubudur O yüzden bu İfade yanlış oldu
gibi zaten yanlış oldukça bu zaman buna
evine olacaktır arkadaşlar Evet sonsuza
bakıyoruz testinin videomuzun bakalım
arkadaşa meslek Bağları Genel bir soru
var burada Hangisi doğru diye
sormuşsunuz metal atomları ile alacağız
sonrasında oluşacak arkadaşlar metalik
bazı adı üstünde nasıl amacı tonlarını
dolusu sadece mesela sonrasında oluşur O
yüzden bu ifadeniz yanlıştır bağ kuvveti
arttıkça doğur meslek bağı sağlamlığı
artar ve metalin sertliğiyle artar
ifadesi Doğrudur Arkadaşlar şimdi
metalik
Bu bir arkadaşlar atıyorum çatla ters
orantılıdır gerçekten orası doğrudan
Dolayısıyla atom çapı arttıkça meslek
balığımızı zayıflığı yapmamız lazım
zayıflar ifadesi doğru olur yani çok
arttıkça metalik bazı zayıflar ama de
erkeklerin sayısı alsaydı metalik bağ
kuvveti artar Evet arkadaşlar
bulacağımız Edirne olmuş oldu Kendinize
iyi bakın görüşmek üzere Arkadaşlar bu